and then yesterday the storm clouds
gathered again
and you could really feel the difference
in the air and then those the
thunderstorms just started developing
even midday boy we sure did feel it and
a lot of places just kind of got
walloped
77 in mountains edge where you had a lot
of rain in that part of the valley
yesterday
81 up in centennial hills the middle of
town got a little rain but it was really
the edges of town southeast valley
got a lot of rain as well from black
mountain to henderson
80 degrees sunrise mountain horizon
ridge got a lot of rain 82 at nellis
we're going to check rain totals here in
just a moment 78 in mesquite the moapa
valley again
clobbered with so much heavy rain 78 in
indian springs you had some
thunderstorms and some good rain as well
81 in front
perhaps seems to keep getting missing
out on the good rainfall
this year so far but remember we're it's
the season is young we still have a ways
to go
79 in searchlight 91 in laughlin 73 in
kingman
with flash flood watches posted for
kingman today
the moapa valley again one to two inches
of rain yesterday
this was on a rainbow about three miles
south of blue diamond
almost an inch and a quarter of rain the
clark county wetlands out on the east
side
an almost an inch in horizon ridge three
quarters of an inch
but there were some areas that did pick
up a little bit more and we appreciate
all of your information when you send us
the info of what you picked up in your
neighborhood maybe you have your own
rain gauge you can keep us posted
officially only a trace so it added
nothing
to the rain total for the year of just a
little over an
inch so at cactus indicator amber thank
you for sending in
this rain video listen to the rain
oh it sounds so good but we had big
claps of thunder yesterday too with
lots of lightning and there were downed
trees unfortunately yesterday there was
some damage with some of the
thunderstorms yesterday and they can
really produce strong outflow winds and
we saw that yesterday
so the monsoon pattern is far and wide
and sometimes it's very concentrated
with these cells like we saw
yesterday the runoff can be very fast
and very dangerous too there are flash
flood watches
for the potential for flash flooding in
northwest arizona including kingman
there today
as well as nye and esmeralda counties
north of amargosa valley
and parum today that's from noon to 8
o'clock we'll continue to sit under this
monsoon pattern
with all that moisture being pulled into
our area today 103
for the afternoon high and again we may
hit that temperature very early in the
day
if the thunderstorm storms come again
early afternoon like they did yesterday
104 tomorrow
get a break tomorrow it looks like and
maybe even wednesday
before the better chance of
thunderstorms thursday friday
slight chance is still into the weekend
highs maybe just under 100 degrees at
the end of the week